uber driver was assaulted by a group of
women after
he requested that one of them put on a a
face mask
now i'm not a big fan of the mask thing
as you know
but i fully respect a guy's right to
tell you the rules for riding in his car
fully respect that if you don't like it
get out of the car
really simple to me it's his car he's
every right to
to set the rules don't like it don't
ride in the car
she didn't like it this woman um but she
refused to get out
of the car and instead she communicated
her um
dislike for this policy by assaulting
him let's watch that video
go
i think you get the idea there these
women these women are
are surely scholars uh so
he he asked her to put the mask on she
didn't want to so she started coughing
in his face
ripped his mask off and tried to steal
his phone
perfectly reasonable reaction right um
and here she is now she she's not uh
she's not apologizing for that here she
is addressing this controversy and kind
of explaining
why she reacted the way that she did
let's
let's listen my boyfriend taught me
he taught me don't let nobody play with
you smack
them that's what i was taught so if
y'all boyfriends
told y'all to let this uber let y'all
get out the car and get
robbed or whatever [ __ ] would have
happened and i saw
y'all know and he lucky as hell i ain't
have nothing on me on mamas cause if you
would have played with me bruh
it would have been a whole different
story for real
you not about to kick me on the freeway
i everybody i know
75 percent of people i know would have
smacked it out of him or done some crazy
off the wall all i did was smack
take his mask off and cough a little bit
but i ain't even have corona so at the
end of the day
okay sorry i just i get so wrapped up
listening to her because she's so
eloquent
um and i i i just enjoy listening to her
express her express herself
in in in that really poetic and profound
way
um two two observations well number one
i i guess it's nice anyway there's a
little bit of chivalry going on here a
little bit of old-fashioned shiver
talking about
her boyfriend is teaching her the things
that her boyfriend teaches her
i think i'd prefer to hear like the
things that her father taught her it
sounds like maybe
there's there's a lack of that which is
which is how this happened in the first
place
well the other two things number one
what you see here is female privilege
okay that she's she's walking around
saying i'll smack anyone i don't care
i'll smack you
well just about any man any any any male
over the age of like 12 could
beat the hell out of her in a second if
they wanted to
but they're not going to for the most
part and so she knows that she can walk
around smacking whoever she wants
i mean we could be pretty sure that's
not the first time she's done that
and she smacked that guy who could
easily take her in a boxing match i'm
sure
but he didn't respond physically and he
knew this is female privilege because he
knew even though he was the one being
attacked
he knew that if he had responded
physically he'd be the one in jail
and she knows that he knows that and so
that's why she's assaulting him
female privilege um and
number two we need to talk a little bit
about dumb person privilege because what
you just saw there
this is why i always go back
to the need to weed out dumb people from
voting
that person right there probably votes
and that's exactly what we need to
address in this country
there is no hope for the future as long
as people like that are helping to
determine it
really simple fifth grade level civics
exam
she's not gonna pass that easily done
something to think about well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content